Drama Series hook up those monitors you
need a wide bore IV it also here that is
Meredith Grey fighting for her life on
the operating table the most dramatic
way to bring back Grey's Anatomy tonight
on ABC and only two shelves on set
please do tell us is Meredith gonna pull
through or knock see if I told you I'd
have to kill you and then Shonda Rhimes
will kill me and I can't have that what
I can tell you is this Denzel Washington
is directing this episode yes I said
Denzel the two-time Oscar winner so hold
on to your couch cushions everybody
there's a shot where it's looking down
on you and the look in your eye when
you're on that tape I was like III would
I was so inspired to go by Denzel I mean
you have to bring your A game for him
Ellen posted these shots of Denzel in
action I mean wouldn't bring their
a-game they did tell me what was going
to happen to Meredith and I said I don't
know if the fans can handle that let's
get back on the bed and then they hit me
with and Denzel is going to direct it
and I said okay I'm down whenever you
want to do I'll do it I did this he was
stable you know dude's got a few statue
sitting on his show couple you kind of
don't want to you know mess it up that
day
of course Denzel was a TV doc himself on
st. elsewhere in the 80s
he's also friends with grey star and
executive producer Debbie Allen is it
true that you actually convinced Denzel
to direct he was at a place where he was
so open and exploring and he said my my
wife loves it knows every character
here's another gray secret Jessica
Capshaw is expecting her fourth child
with husband Christopher Gavigan who is
one of the founders of Jessica Alba's
honest company props will be adjusted on
the set to conceal that baby bump has
there been a lot of hiding behind and
just grocery bags
I thought it was so fatigue they're like
let me just move this table over here
and I was like that's in funny the
tables in front of me it was right here